à peine deux jours après sa sortie du
tribunal de vesoul et sa condamnation à
deux mois de prison avec sursis
céline roy revient dans le mouvement des
gilet jaune un acte deux structures et
qui va s'inscrire dans la durée avec la
naissance d'une association la maison
des gilet jaune la maison des gilets
jaunes donc qui a pour but ben de pu
être juré rond point mais manière
administrative etc
aller à la rencontre des gens ben voilà
on aura une permanence au centre ville
qui va nous permettre de recevoir des
gens de de prendre des rendez vous avec
des élus mais beaucoup plus structurée
qu'avant puis fut sur le tas et voilà on
a beaucoup beaucoup de projets comme la
publication d'un livre
pour les gilet jaune mais c'est une
associée au cal s'est pas du tout pour
toute la france complète c'est vraiment
locale parce qu'on peut pas se permettre
de parler pour les personnes qui sont
dans le sud qui sont à l'ouest externe
n'a pas du tout les mêmes problèmes des
gilets jaunes qui souhaitent se
structure et maintenant comme ici à
vesoul et c'est une première dans la
région est sûrement en france ne reste
plus maintenant qu'à trouver un local